dans l'espace liminal entre rêve et réalité,
entre race et sexe,
entre pauvreté et aisance,
entre science et société.
Je suis noire et une femme.
Telle la naissance des étoiles dans le firmament,
cette combinaison solide de savoir aboutit à un exemple flamboyant
d'identités multiples qui fusionnent.
Je suis aussi astrophysicienne.
J'étudie les blazars, des trous noirs super massifs et super actifs,
localisés aux centres de galaxies immenses.
Ils éjectent des jets à proximité de ces trous noirs,
à une vitesse proche de celle de la lumière.
C'est un phénomène que nous cherchons à comprendre.
Je rêve de devenir astrophysicienne
depuis que j'ai 12 ans.
A cette époque, j'ignorais totalement
que seules 18 femmes afro-américaines avaient obtenu un doctorat en physique,
selon les archives sur les femmes physiciennes afro-américaines
compilées par le Dr. Jamie Alexander.
J'ignorais que la première femme noire à avoir reçu un doctorat en astro-physique,
l'avait obtenu un an seulement avant ma naissance.
Dans ma vie,
j'ai rencontré le meilleur et le pire que la vie offre, à des intersections :
l'opportunité incroyable de pouvoir me définir,
la collision entre espoirs et expérience,
l'euphorie grisante de découvertes victorieuses,
et parfois,
la douleur intense de devoir se régénérer.
J'ai commencé l'université peu après l'implosion de ma famille.
Notre situation financière s'est effondrée quand mon père nous a quittées.
Son départ nous a bannies, ma mère, ma sœur et moi,
du confort relatif de la classe moyenne,
et nous a projetées dans le combat incessant pour joindre les deux bouts.
Je fais donc partie des 60% de femmes de couleur
pour lesquelles trouver des ressources financières
s'avère un obstacle majeur à leur réussite académique.
L'Université de Norfolk State a financé la totalité de mes études,
grâce à elle, j'ai pu obtenir une licence en physique.
Après ma licence, je souhaitais continuer vers le doctorat.
Ce souhait ne m'a pas empêchée de passer entre les mailles du filet.
C'est un poster qui a empêché mon rêve de sombrer,
et des personnes impressionnantes, et de bons programmes.
La Société Américaine des Physiciens avait créé un poster magnifique
destiné à encourager les étudiants de couleur à devenir physiciens.
Ce poster m'a impressionnée car il représentait une fillette noire,
d'environ 12 ans,
qui observait des équations de physique.
Je me souviens clairement qu'à ce moment,
je me suis aperçue que j'observais une petite fille
qui avait le courage de rêver son rêve.
J'ai écrit à la Société immédiatement,
pour leur demander une copie de ce poster.
Aujourd'hui, il orne encore mon bureau.
Dans cet email, j'avais décrit mon parcours académique,
et mon souhait de continuer sur la voie du doctorat.
Ils m'ont suggéré de m'adresser au programme pont
des universités Fisk-Vanderbilt.
Ce programme est à l'intersection des diplômes de licence et de doctorat
des deux universités.
Ils m'ont acceptée deux ans après que j'ai reçu mon diplôme.
Je me suis retrouvée sur la route du doctorat.
J'ai reçu mon master à Fisk,
et j'ai continué mon doctorat à Yale.
Je remplissais physiquement l'espace qui allait me permettre
de réaliser mes aspirations d'enfance.
Je pensais que mon doctorat aller passer comme une lettre à la poste.
(Rires)
Il m'est vite apparu
que tout le monde n'était pas enchanté d'accueillir une occupante aussi liminale
dans leur espace.
Mes collègues de classe m'ont ségréguée,
une d'entre elles a jugé bon de m'inviter « à faire ce pour quoi j'étais venue, »
en poussant vers moi les assiettes sales pour me faire faire la vaisselle.
J'eus espéré que cette histoire soit un cas isolé.
Hélas, de nombreuses femmes de couleur,
dans les sciences, la technologie, les sciences de l'ingénieur, et les maths,
ont enduré et continuent de subir ces actes.
100% des 60 femmes de couleur interviewées
dans une étude récente réalisée par Joan Williams,
ont admis avoir subi des préjugés sexuels et racistes,
tels qu'être vue comme une femme de ménage.
Aucune femme blanche interviewée dans le cadre de l'étude,
n'a reporté une telle méprise d'identité.
On parle de 557 femmes blanches.
Il n'y a rien de négatif à faire partie du personnel d'entretien.
Mes aïeuls ont pu recevoir une éducation,
parce que leurs parents ont rempli ces fonctions.
Il s'agissait de me remettre à ma place.
Certes, cette rencontre fut douloureuse,
mais le fait est que mon apparition seule
est une claire indication de mes aptitudes.
Au-delà de ça, cette rencontre malencontreuse
souligne le fait que les femmes de couleur affrontent des obstacles plus importants
que les femmes « normales », ou que les hommes de couleur.
Voilà pourquoi je tiens à encourager les femmes de couleur dans les sciences.
Des femmes qui inexorablement, systématiquement,
sont la somme d'identités inséparables.
Les sciences sont également un ensemble d'intersections.
Leur vraie valeur ne peut pas être appréciée
sans prendre en compte l'espace liminal entre chaque discipline.
Sans les mathématiques, on ne peut pas étudier la science,
la poursuite de la compréhension du monde physique,
à travers des phénomènes chimiques, physiques et biologiques.
La science de l'ingénieur a besoin des sciences fondamentales et des maths
pour être appliquée dans le monde réel.
La technologie est ancrée dans les maths,
les sciences de l'ingénieur, et les sciences.
Les mathématiques remplissent le rôle essentiel de la pierre de Rosette :
décoder et encoder les principes physiques du monde.
Les sciences sont lacunaires s'il manque un seul de ces éléments.
Leur valeur est décuplée
quand on les combine à d'autres disciplines.
J'ai deux messages pour vous :
le premier est que vous soyez noire, latino, au autochtone,
ou une femme avec d'autres caractéristiques,
si vous vous trouvez à la croisée des chemins,
de race et de genre,
vous pouvez devenir tout ce que vous souhaitez.
Personnellement, j'espère que vous deviendrez astrophysicienne,
mais que vous réalisiez vos rêves est le plus important.
Ne pensez jamais un seul instant,
que « qui vous êtes »
vous empêche de devenir qui vous imaginez devenir.
Accrochez-vous à vos rêves,
et autorisez-les à vous emmener dans un monde
que vous n'avez jamais imaginé.
Ensuite, les enjeux les plus importants dans le monde
trouvent des solutions là où les sciences se croisent.
Notre société mondiale a résolu
la plupart des questions simples qui se sont présentées à nous.
Celles qui restent nécessitent que nous investiguions en profondeur
les espaces liminaux entre les disciplines,
afin de créer les solutions multi-facettes du futur.
Qui d'autre pourrait mieux résoudre ces problèmes liminaux
que ceux et celles qui ont vécu leur vie à la croisée des chemins ?
En tant que dirigeants et décideurs,
nous devons dépasser les prémices de la diversité,
et explorer le territoire plus fertile de l'inclusion sociale,
et d'opportunité égale pour tous.
J'aime citer en exemple d'excellence liminale,
le Dr. Claudia Alexander, qui est décédée récemment.
Une femme noire, physicienne en plasma.
Elle est décédée en juillet,
après avoir combattu le cancer du sein pendant 10 ans.
Elle était une scientifique à la NASA.
Elle y a forgé le programme de la mission Rosetta,
devenue célèbre cette année en faisant atterrir une sonde sur une comète,
et de la mission Galiléo à destination de Jupiter,
un programme de 1,5 milliard de dollars.
Il s'agit de deux victoires scientifiques d'envergure
pour la NASA, les États-Unis, et le monde.
Le Dr. Alexander a dit ceci :
« J'ai l'habitude d'être à cheval entre deux cultures.
Une de mes missions dans ma vie
consiste à nous élever d'un état d'ignorance vers un état de compréhension,
avec des recherches téméraires, rares et inhabituelles. »
Tel est le pouvoir des personnes liminales.
Elle possédait la capacité technique pour diriger
les missions d'exploration spatiale les plus ambitieuses.
Elle savait exactement quel était son rôle,
en étant précisément elle-même, partout où elle se trouvait.
Jessica Matthews est l'inventeur de la ligne de sport SOCCKET,
des ballons de foot qui génèrent de l'énergie renouvelable,
quand on joue avec.
Elle a dit ceci :
« Une portion importante de l'invention n'est pas de créer des choses,
mais bien de comprendre les gens,
et les systèmes qui sont à la base du fonctionnement de la société. »
Si je vous raconte mon histoire,
celle du Dr. Alexander, et de Jessica Matthews,
c'est parce que ce sont des histoires à la croisée des chemins,
de histoires de vie au cœur des questions raciales, de genre, et d'innovation.
En dépit des questions implicites et explicites
quant à mon droit de faire partie de l'élite,
je suis fière du fait que, lorsque j'ai reçu mon diplôme,
j'étais la première femme noire à recevoir un doctorat en astrophysique
de l'Université de Yale, sur ses 312 ans d'existence.
(Applaudissements)
Je fais aujourd'hui partie d'un petit groupe grandissant
de femmes de couleur actives dans les sciences,
prêtes à apporter des perspectives neuves, et à concrétiser des idées neuves
pour résoudre les défis de notre temps :
l'inégalité dans l'éducation,
la violence policière, le SIDA, le changement climatique,
l'édition génomique, l'intelligence artificielle, ou l'exploration sur Mars.
Il y a aussi toutes ces choses auxquelles nous n'avons pas encore pensé.
Les femmes de couleur dans les sciences sont au centre
d'un des défis socio-technologiques les plus rudes, les plus enthousiasmants.
Notre vécu nous positionnent idéalement
pour permettre de contribuer et diriger ces débats
de façon plus inclusive et plus diversifiée.
Ceci est valable pour les nombreuses personnes à l'intersection,
dont l'expérience, positive et négative,
permet d'enrichir les débats sans aucune mesure avec le fruit
de discussions au sein des meilleures équipes, mais homogènes.
Ce n'est pas le fruit d'un désir de s'intégrer.
C'est une cuti qui nous rappelle que le meilleur n'est pas atteignable
pour l'humanité dans son intégralité
sans cette collaboration,
sans l'inclusion du liminal,
des vécus différents, des expériences particulières,
qui ont des impacts sur chaque individu.
En un mot, nous ne pouvons pas exprimer
le meilleur de notre génie collectif,
sans y associer la totalité de l'humanité.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)